devenir analyste en cyber sécurité ou
assistant de sécurisation de données
dès la rentrée treize formation
labellisée école du numérique seront
disponibles sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
en tout 300 futurs talents s'apprête à
être formés c'est les emplois de demain
vous savez bien et puis les entreprises
nous ont fait part de leurs besoins et
on a souhaité venir d organiser
formation qui n'était pas à saint
quentin en yvelines pour qu'elles
proposent des formations qui
correspondent aux besoins des
entreprises
cet organisme ont présenté leur
formation comme o'clock
il propose de vous apprendre les bases
du métier de développeur web tout en
restant chez vous on est à distance
sujet soit la plupart du temps à
domicile mais en interaction permanente
avec un formateur qui est en direct
vidéo avec qui on échange comme comme
s'il était à côté et on l'entend il nous
entend on peut lui parler et en
interaction permanente aussi avec les
autres stagiaires de la formation
commence tous les jours à 9 heures
jusqu'à midi après une pause pour
déjeuner à 13 en europe rend jusqu'à 15
heures
la plupart de ces formations est
accessible sans diplôme particulier et
s'adresse donc un large public
j'ai un petit job hors intérimaires et
cette année j'ai envie de me reconvertir
dans le numérique
je trouvais ce que cherche à au moins
trois formations qui m'intéresse
beaucoup
le numérique un secteur d'avenir à saint
quentin en yvelines qui a recensé en un
an dix mille offres d'emploi